all right i'm changing the expedition
you guys are just going to complain
yeah
you should pick a spirit
oh yeah dude i want to be a spear boy
yeah you should be spear spears dope can
i go potty again oh my gosh
potty
chugging gallons of water over there oh
my god
hi guys
you made it there's a lot of crotch
pressure yeah i'm gonna start never been
hoisted by my dick before no what did
you guys talk about while i was you
missed a lot apparently i did you ever
um did you just go to king's island to
ride the tomb raider ride yeah
that's oh yeah why did you buy your dick
oh yeah oh my god there's one here hello
[Music]
yep i forgot they could be here nice
work team nice work team good job
everybody i have a matter of protector
in my hand i can't help oh you do don't
you uh okay we got two you can drop it
if you hold the you can drop it okay i'm
gonna start using the i'm gonna start
using the compass as like directional we
add uh uh there's a console here
300 up there there's actually we don't
matter where
jump gate in zone 38 you could query
zone 38 maybe query zone 38 oh that's
not a console that's what you were
saying out loud with your words
are there stuff behind any of these
doors back here mark
uh
which doors are you referring to what's
that oh that door yes i found a terminal
right here bob you're going to improv
what does mcfc and underground for
my [ __ ]
you know it's my fault for tossing it to
you you really just love that one right
over the plate i don't know what you
thought it was gonna happen
what am i looking for zone 38 that's my
favorite animated porn
list sell wait we need listen
generator 452 we need to turn on power
to open this door cell 813 item type
unknown status normal end of list
uh yeah generator underscore four five
two four five two i'm hacking the
mainframe right now nice hack faster
please
uh backup power generator hey no your
spears your spear's in the way okay
unpowered location zone 31 in range for
ping hey sean come here
uh there it is
oh now you got the vaccine i did it do
you run fast now uh no
he looked like a meth addict running
around with a giant
generator located in zone 32 not in
range for ping that's where all the
enemies are so we got to open this door
we gotta go 32 lads 32
oh wait there's there's things on the
other side of that door be aware
okay
can you hack it yeah we got a stack of
three spaced five meters apart directly
in front of this door
all right well hope you're all ready
because here we go
never mind they're below
oh the music just [ __ ] amped up they
are below
i can't
there was one right below the stairs but
spear has long ranged baby so long man
oh my god it does okay i got this guy i
got this guy three one
nice oh spiro p we got one more down
here somewhere look at this this one
is clear
look at this condensated glass effect
it's so dope i know it's very pretty
it's cold in here right so it's like
it's like streaky ice crystals forming
yeah it's beautiful like a plain window
wow
you know why i don't need to bring the
thing with us here found in cavity 166
of excavation deep reach
what is this
what did you find and talking it's
talking about the plants in the glass
it's made out of carbon oxygen sulfur in
traces of iridium
whatever already right they found a
problem what's wrong
oh never mind that's cool oh i thought
spiritual break lock all right 120
meters away from door so pretty far real
life
had a bit of a diarrhea in my brain
i'm afraid of light not in this room
maybe
it could be down it could be down
down to clown
yeah it wasn't this room it's the next
room one on the other side of this
doorway
uh i'm at the other door i'll come to
you guys yeah he's he's clear
always but ice is down here hacking [ __ ]
yeah just be aware there's one there's
one around you
sean i i don't know where though
it's like right on the other side of
this door
do you want to guess where he is in
charge already
oh hey there he is hi
who's gonna get it
oh we all did there's one over there
i can't run in charge at the same time
radiation readings nominal hey sean you
don't happen to still be carrying that
wave projector that i see way back there
[Music]
we need to go through that other door
after we get the generator he said he
was gonna set it down yeah he did yeah
you're right you're right you call it a
wave projector
zone 33 do we have a door in here to
zone 33 um uh 32 here not okay so we got
to keep going
yeah
don't worry guys [ __ ] i'ma hack it well
it's too it's good
over here uh there's a lot on the other
side of that door there's a lot on the
other side of that door just f1 all
right it's open now
holy [ __ ]
they're in tubes
not all of them are in tubes
oh don't splash me daddy don't say that
wait a minute oh there's a guy right
right i'm coming stop stop stop
hello i'm here now oh hey man
there's five of them and four of us well
the one on that side of the thing he
could probably be killed over this part
what does it mean i was really hoping
you were just gonna say there's five of
them and i'm getting this guy
okay
all right that's good that's good the
the cases seem to block their line of
sight oh god oh my god
please
have mercy on my soul
oh god what's happening
awake now okay
get him
there we go oh one'll spawn over there
in the distance far on and let me tag
him
yep
that's fine that's fine
that was a snipe from around the corner
that's cheating
they curved it's it's the movie wanted
in this universe mine curves too but
doctor said that wasn't normal oh wait i
just got a motion reading there's
something moving on the other side of
that door might be the patrol it's gonna
be a slurpee alarm yes can you do the
super scan and ping it uh yep
there it is but we gotta do with the
alarm first anyway
oh yeah
dancing
there's gonna be enemies coming at us
from the alarm door oh i'm gonna open
this door no no leave leave it locked no
we came in that door they still just
break through it the same way oh i don't
know oh i guess you're right never mind
you know what we'll find out all right
i'm ready when you guys are
do we have anything on that door in case
they come that way i am going to put my
turret up on top of this thing facing
this way after we do the security
circles okay
yeah
good call
big boy left left
yep well i guess it still could be
anywhere
they are coming through that door yes
one more one more
[Applause]
there's three more over there coming
through that door many coming through
that door circles circles are up
and i'm trying to tag these guys they're
hard to see is there one right here
coming
where's this other circle
incoming they're getting through they're
getting through i'm getting asked
where's this other circle here i found
it
nice can we get them all
right more coming through
lord
ow fans are done oh that one was not
dead
manny oh he lagged oh he laggy oh wow
there's a lot of these [ __ ] yep there
are
ow oh my god i'm getting nailed
ow
one more oh we're off here
look out i can't hit him for [ __ ]
i hit all the right guy in all the wrong
places okay we're clear
that could've gone better
guess which door they didn't even touch
that's not awful
for next time yeah yeah yeah uh
no one's got a med kit right i'm
guessing that i have a no i don't
all right is this a tendril dude the
next door tendril
he is
i've got my snip snaps he's a little far
but there he is
while i'm far away go for it
okay
if someone has a sniper
i got my snip snaps i'm stamping snap
them
it's nerf is it immune whenever tendrils
are out or something wasn't there like
yeah do not shoot when tendrils
touch them hey tendrilling
oh excuse me sir or madam
easy peasy idiots
just suck your starbursts in you
douchebag
here it goes
[Music]
i felt that in my loins that was nice
really clear room clear perfect time to
say he got bobbled
[Music]
uh is this room safe are we saving this
safe room clear room clear
okay good good it would have terminal
things off right i know i just heard
screams in the distance just you know
that was good
back where we were that's just our
audience who bet that we would die there
oh i got stuff they lost a lot of money
well done
let's go
all right i got the wave projector oh
now you want it well you're carrying
that so someone had to carry this oh
helpful are you i ain't some wheelie bin
gamer
wow
that's a throwback that is a throwback
audience but in here slam it
go in here yeah slam it in insert your
cell into the boot
okay this isn't like an alarm or
anything is it it's not a scary one
though
it's green you're fine okay good
flashlight
question mark oh sorry
uh yeah two on the bottom uh three three
three
two
two three two at 3 30.
sorry i was in my settings let's
apologize okay there's two guys two guys
down here next to me i'm making my way
downtown
stabbing ass and we're hell-bound
you want to get the you want to get the
right one
oh my god
[Laughter]
that was a play in the game right there
thank you yeah that uh i took years off
my life
and he doesn't have that many mom and i
are just like all right you go left i'll
go right all right one two break [ __ ]
tarzan and come swinging in from out of
goddamn nowhere
george of the jungle than it was
i think that is a compliment
brendan fraser i want a man
i have a matter way if you go get him
all right yeah we got they're all
separated out but there are some pretty
much in every direction wait is there
any in this corner there's two in that
corner yes
and there's one to the left around the
corner
there is one in that corner there i only
see one i guarantee you there's one in
the corner there's not one oh it's above
it
okay what i thought you were just about
to run into him all i see is dicey's
name just like charging at a guy oh he's
up the stairs i got him
oh [ __ ] i started a hack i shouldn't
have done that oh
he was big he teleported on my screen
they shoot so far
yeah they got big
big lickers yeah they do
okay down down dead
out fall damage hey fall damage mark
yeah you're right
right one dead yeah i was like going
around the corner all confident charging
my my spear and then i stabbed it and
did nothing oh
all right terminal here do we need to
look for anything uh health would be
great we need to get his own 30 i got a
health no i gave you a health terminator
and alf terminal and alpha 2 what is it
terminator and alpha 2. that'd be an
awful enemy
yeah where's where's alpha 2 our
objective says locate terminal and alpha
2 and extract data cube coordinates
there's an important door down here
mark see where the purple key is purple
240.
okay is it is it key purple what is it
yeah it's key underscore purple
underscore i think it's 230 240. 240.
okay query
oh there it is yeah it's this way i'll
be there in a uh zone 36 security door
over here he's in zone 36 come on down
boys where are you how do you wait
wait we're at the wrong one yeah
oh i see ics okay i got you i got you we
got one across the door just uh
three
three thirty one and then at three
hundred
twenty meters away another one
i'm sure we'd all remember that yep you
got it is
and then another one no no foul
propellers oh
oh
sweet baby back it should just be the
one here yep and he's not a big
shoop and then one down the hallway
there
to the left there yeah to the left
i could take these glow sticks no i
can't the syringe where's the syringe
dude
i don't know what the orange is that i
am 15 infected yeah wait there's
infection in this right uh i forgot
about it i hate that mechanic wait where
do you see that where do you see your
percent infection shows up on your
health bar right yeah it's right above i
that's what the syringe does guys
because she wanted to know oh yeah and
there's stations that you can take it
off yeah um we got three looks like on
the other side of that door we should be
okay here where's the fog repeller put
that [ __ ] down
it doesn't do like nice area
all right i'm hacking
oh well
this is some fogging fog
yeah i see a big guy definitely in this
room in this room where i'm not seeing
them over here to the right
oh yeah there he is far enough away i'm
going to go up top
hacking
wait just don't do that dude
there's a little guy a little guy passed
that big guy more fog
oops stop it stop stop please all right
don't do it wait do you want to take out
that dude
together
all of us uh
there's one that shawn's gonna be able
to take out yeah i'm on them guys i've
got veins on the corner of my vision
just letting you know
use it to focus you
okay sean you should be able to take
them out now whenever yeah okay that one
good uh
yeah i'm here oh god
where are we doing are we doing
butts or brains
i'll get the head
i'll also get a top you still flail
i will aim for an up part
okay charging charging charging
three two one
oh god not dead not
dead he's
[Music]
31 33 35 37 38 we need any of these
36 30
i can't explain this to you is this the
one where where are you guys it's just
oh yeah yeah
yep
you can see him from here is it a good
shot
yeah you can sign in this box to get a
better one
no no when he stands back up i got this
all right wishing you luck oh yeah
he was gone
oh there's a little guy here yeah be
careful there are little guys one in
front of you and then uh that's that's
all i see for now can you keep the big o
pinned
pinged uh yeah
i'm gonna go for the little guy
yeah if you can take him out and drills
if those things there's really long
right no they're long quite a ways yeah
okay uh watch out bob there is a small
one
okay yeah uh you can get a clear shot
from where we are right here bob
yeah wait where are you right over here
to your left
oh yeah coming this way
yeah
nice
good shot good shot good job another one
another one there's a something's moving
it's a little one it's a little one
you got him
uh he's dead okay he did not wake up
anybody clear
hey
everywhere uh class four alarm oh
well it's either better or worse i guess
we'll find out
i think we toss the fog repeller right
before we start yeah there's two doors
in here right there's one south side and
one i'm on
yes yes i think yeah i've ever seen from
grenade i can toss on one do we
definitely need to do this uh sean this
is the crazy ass security door
i'm guessing
zone 35 do we need to do this
i mean zone 36 is what we need right
it doesn't say that it goes to other
zones it just says zone 35 oh uh well
we've already formed our way in so yes
okay well we're doing it all right i
guess
uh but not a fog repeller are we good i
think so uh yeah we do it i guess right
oh man
my vision is veiny
throbbing vision it really is
oh so much less fog
that is nice i hear the roars
that's left all right
big circle don't make us go stand in the
turret
don't do it okay we got incoming they're
coming left by the looks of it
back the other way there they are
okay oh i know right here
yep here they come there are so many
right there
following the thingy
oh god it's a big one
oh wow oh wow oh there is a big one
there's a big one i'm sniping down the
big one okay
i can't because i'm being actually
killed by a bunch of little ones in my
face
got him
coming to the circle
another big guy coming
door unlocked uh
one more coming in two more coming in
three more coming in
and three more left man every time i
choose a place to put my turret it's the
wrong one
you're covering our backs
where's that one hiding what's he doing
where are you
oh he's stuck on something all right uh
he's just a wiggle that was well handled
uh and our fog repellers just ran out i
think i i
bob i think there is one
moving here yeah i got it tagged him
watch out there are things on the other
side of that door oh i can't see she's
there
oh big they're stacked three meters
apart from another night
i'm gonna let you guys clear some of the
little ones for a minute before i even
try and get a shot on the tentacle good
cool i don't want to get stuck somewhere
where i'd cut off the alarm this is a
normal sized guy is this a there's a
normal sized guy right oh yeah it is he
just looks big mark how close is
tentacles he's far he's about 30. i
think we can get these two wait yeah
you're good yeah
three two one
charged yet that worked one of them woke
up one worked out [ __ ] big guy big guy
woke up
he was a locker drama drama drama
get away from the door back away from
the door back way back going away from
the door oh god
how
rude mark can you
hang tentacles yeah he's he's not coming
we're good okay he's right there yeah on
the other side everyone's really crying
out in pain i am not doing very well
tentacles is approaching oh no
neither he's not affected i'm fired
we're all very much damaged
oh damage well that probably kind of
cleared this area out
uh oh on the other side of this door
we're clear in this room
yeah he's on the other side oh please be
health after fact what am i looking at
no artifact good we can boost we get
boost
yeah but i won't boost now not boost
later uh i have 30 percent health is
anyone lower um yeah uh 26. but
i'm nedpack
thinking
do we need to query anything oh we need
to look for a key purple
we're not in the zone yet though are we
i don't like that i can't 36 36 i
believe all right uh we got movie
tentacles
right on the other side of there
and then there's there's one dude where
that
triangle was just standing there's
another dude these are both 35b so i
guess it doesn't really matter which way
we go home yeah probably both the same
uh technical man
there's one on the other side of the
store right where i'm looking we can
snag them right now the tentacle is
right by wade
it's a big egg it's big it's big man
i wish we had the grenades
yeah grenades would be good um where's
the big oh he's right there can you
snipe the big can would that kill him
if i snipe him yeah uh no it's not a one
shot oh damn okay i can snipe him and
then you guys can all melee tentacle man
approaching
oh yep
moving he's coming up the stairs
watch out they can come in here
oh i see it oh the one you can see
where are you
all right well that's gonna make getting
the big very risky just snipe the the
tentacle man he's coming he's coming be
careful
oh sorry i didn't realize it dropped
there he is
what a penis
don't do it keep going oh you got it
nice good shot guy woke up do not go
around the clock
oh hell yeah dude oh it is a one shot
mvp
bob over here
[Laughter]
better every time better every day
all right the uh room is not clear do
not go running into the darkness uh hey
light boy
there's there is one in front of me and
i have a name i really hope it's not a
big one it's light man
i don't see it i don't see it
wow
could you uh
take him and snipe him yeah well you
can't play him no he's like okay he's
going to glow because i'm going to he's
right there he's right here he's all
right
oh god no what is someone doing
i cannot see his head i will slash
i will flashlight him oh god it's
repelled okay yeah oh whoa can you see
him oh wait wait a perfect perk yeah i
pop him poppy please
okay oh
poppy play time we have confirmed it's a
one shot
i wish we knew that before
stupid and stinky
live and learn
okay you don't scan that or anything
that's fine yeah nice
way to go light man is it where we were
damn that sounds cool
this is where we were this is where we
did the security door yeah yeah okay
cool
that was a big loop that we just did for
nothing at all
uh yeah nothing
we did that for nothing well now hold on
we got to have the journey along the way
we had fun the real treasure is the
friends i already had before we wasted
all that time oh hey
where do we actually need to go 36
or 37 uh yeah probably the door i'm at
that says zone 36 that we passed oh [ __ ]
wait
wait your turret's still down by the
bottom i know i came to get my turn i
just happened to run right into the
objective three feet from where i put it
down oh [ __ ]
on the bright side though this door is
already foamed oh yeah i know that's
safe that's nice oh yeah zone 36 look at
that and it's a class four
that's fine we just did one of those so
it's not a big deal
i'm running all the way back around to
put my turn on the other side of the
foam door
[Laughter]
my turf was in the right place just the
wrong side
yeah yeah actually i don't think there's
any way they're gonna come through that
door i'm
almost positive they would come down
through the south that's definitely true
we should trust mark's judgment on this
one hey this is already here so there's
fog blowers over here no wait there's no
way there's no entrance from that zone
for enemies to come from
so what we but they were behind the
security door so we if we just left that
security door locked those guys couldn't
have gotten out yeah i guarantee you
they're gonna come from the south
approach i believe you already know that
kind of bad information bob and it
doesn't help our current situation
okay okay good information good vibes
right you're right you're right vibes
good vibes you're right wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
we putting a turn on the other side of
that door are we are we isn't that the
only other one that can come in so if we
put the turret and foam it that would be
like wait what's always wrong with their
turrets
i'm gonna do this so that your turret
can get some sweet action okay
oh wait that so you're saying my door is
the right door no no probably so you're
wrong so now you're double wrongs you
have to be right no no no no i'm a i'm a
tongue and you're a sweet hole
what
no no he's right he's right he's right
what's saying was that supposed to be
i'm just being a little tongue in hole
you know
everyone always says i'm holy
oh look they're coming through the other
one oh yeah oh
my god
technically that's bob alone
oh yeah they are going
right now
that's two country
we good uh oh no not yet no not yet
world's slowest [ __ ] thing here we go
come on baby where is it where is it
where is it
i went down i went down
don't go through that door there is
things on the other side
wow
big man
get down bubba
he's still alive he's not a man
no ass no peen no head no arms no tongue
clear no tongue clear clear
clear well now my turret's really
trapped is there another way into that
room yeah
oh i took it for you you were going to
do that way and i took the fall for you
so you could get a little bit of glory
so you're well feels good to be good
daddy oh
all right
what happened to you
a new year new me
new doesn't mean better
no it does not thank you for noticing
all right we got one spaghetti boy we
got two
uh dudes on the other side oh spaghetti
boy yeah
that's what they called me in college
two dudes directly in front they're
definitely not bad
ones big
they are big
sleepers
where are oh right there they might be
big but we have a bob
yeah we got a bob
uh so
how do we do this we'll need to get the
small one
a tubing oh it's too big
it is too big would you look at that
whatever you stand like over there yeah
by my seafoam door you might be able to
double tap them or yo
oh yeah maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe
maybe wait he's wait he can see us
i can see both of them but they're not
lined up oh
do you want me to try and go bang bang
yeah go bang bang yeah everybody
everybody ready for a little action yep
oh yeah
did you do this
can you follow it up with us spaghetti
kill hey there's a there's a walking up
oh no that's a tentacle boy spaghetti
get him get him shoot him bob shoot him
shoot him in line of sight
i can't tell if he's in the fog or
behind a wall he's behind him he's
behind the wall
okay okay yeah bob yeah bobby
that was sick actually he's on the other
side of that door we're clear we got the
terminal is that a medpacker in there oh
yeah
he purple 240. i'm pinging the key baby
all right oh it all right here 36 see
it
yeah it's uh
through this door where there's a
new cool cool cool
all right be careful there are four
they're not next to the door they're
about fifteen
i think he's far enough away
you think that
he's a licker chucking a glow stick
i don't see [ __ ]
they are here
i am gonna angle for a shot on the
annoying
down right below you just be careful i
can't tell if he's in the darkness and
fog or what i'm trying to track tentacle
boy he's like behind a wall oh there's
two right on yeah yeah no he's not
behind the wall he's right there okay
i'll go around okay
i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait on
tentacles he's far away okay all right
let's do this
okay you might want to keep him painted
though what
yeah let me ping him
uh pinging him there he is oh i got the
blood on the screen watch that there's
one more around the corner he's moving
he's moving yeah i'm watching i'm
watching i'm watching
otherwise
oh [ __ ] that might be close enough to
touch me don't like
whoa whoa whoa whoa what's happening
is that another one yeah there's
something here i just can't see it the
fog is so thick
oh thick air
it's it's coming closer he's coming
close it's saying it's right on top of
me but i don't see it
i see it i see oh oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god tentacles i'm sorry i'm
sorry i couldn't see him i'm stuck here
oh
this is
[Laughter]
where is this other smelly boy oh they
woke up woke up woke up
get that one get that one
more more more lots more a lot more over
here
i'm turning up
no i'm not letting me hurt i'm down
you're down
oh i'm down god damn it
yeah
i didn't realize there were so many yeah
oh [ __ ] oh
no oh
[Music]
oh checkpoint wait restart from his
latest checkpoint oh yeah let's go
oh
where are we what happened oh i have a
seafoam grenade that's way back
now we don't have to go through that
stupid door oh yeah we don't have to go
right there's a guy here yeah there are
oh yes sorry uh yeah one there's space
oh this is the room where there was like
one off to the right and that was it i
think right away
i think so
hold still we went we went this way and
then we're
uh to the left there we're we're not too
far away from where we were oh yeah we
have to go through that one right there
yeah exactly we just have to do that
event again whoa
my gameplay is in here oh okay
you guys were just floating spears and
heads
do you think people come through the
same doors last time or is it randomized
uh well there's a big no there's a bag
over there if we never open that other
security door which we didn't they can't
come through there so we should be cool
right
everyone's seeing that right oh yeah
there's that guy's still there yeah do i
get them or do it is there anything
snap them in half go ahead and if there
is i'll put a turret down we can fall
back
i'm not seeing anything on that on the
radar
oh wait there was uh there was one there
was no guys
no there's a bunch no no no no a bunch
oh
one more i don't know that's a
tentacle dude that's it oh okay we're
good we're good oh you're gonna go for
uh go through like zone 35 just for
[ __ ] kicks yeah just see what says oh
yeah man yeah these are lunatics you're
[ __ ] lunatics can they since we
didn't clear that area can they actually
bust through that way like all the [ __ ]
they know they can't go through security
doors yeah so we should just block up
this one door and we should be good a
nice weight you want to put a turret
outside of it i know you love that i do
love that
don't want to put your tongue in that
hole
or whatever the hell you were saying
wait is wade putting his
there
telling you that security door on the
other side is now closed so
he said it as we came into this room you
clarified it again uh you still went
over there i'm saying this room
all right so maybe he's got a point
look okay why is it clear can we just
clear 34a real quick then and not open
that door no that's baby tactics
okay then i'm just going to open the
door put my turret in and leave real man
tactics is dying tentacles yeah yeah
holy god
i thought the glowing red triangle was a
little obvious oh they're here and there
you go yeah there he is do i blast him
or do i not blast him
yeah blast him i think he's just i don't
want to risk him coming neutral
all right he's got oh we got incoming
there's pads coming
down pinging
come on pick there we go one watch those
corners
cool and clear let's make it happen
captain i'm gonna reserve my turret for
the alamo situation i love that sweet
icy quite dicey i was throwing fog
repellers sorry come here
i'm here
what was that
all right they're coming through that
door south side door
well that's unfortunate
all right are something's gonna be the
same okay spreading that i'm going up
yeah these are all the same uh turret
down bob uh yeah bob
got it okay incoming
they're good they're through
oh this is a fortune angle
or a great angle actually
there's a lie coming through there's a
hole done
ouchy ouchy
okay you're good
uh there's a few left from that door
god the fog can't see [ __ ] yeah yeah
trying to ping again
pinged whoa
oh my god i'm going up high yeah i get
just yeah back up
yeah kite come up the stairs
this is actually a way better angle why
didn't we come up here first yeah that's
a smart tactic
clear all right so we didn't go through
that other door and yet i'm somehow
still at the same health as last time
it's almost like it was the same amount
of enemies i think this is the case
where that tentacle is on the other side
of another door over here we just got
two
yeah there's just two here to the right
or directly in front
they're big i remember these are the big
ones oh the big guys that oh bob
right yeah yeah i got this you got this
you fellas ready i am yeah
already
wait a minute i need to stop
so we need to like clear some more of
this next room before we wake them up by
murdering the tentacles if we can
yeah that's really the tricky [ __ ] what
else
he does he does get close to this door
he really does
go ahead and open that open that door
wait
no yes
open and back off yeah yes yeah oh my
god oh he's doing it yeah
he's doing the thing
it's right there so he goes all the way
down to the left when he's walking away
from us he goes away for a good amount
of time before he comes back yeah how
many dudes are in there four i'm seeing
one two three four five
six
seven
seven in there
right there yeah yeah
bob that is a clear shot i think
i can't see him no he's still behind
you can get him though when he's going
back now should i try and get him now
yeah yeah wait wait sorry
ah too late
all right incoming
turning on the door
walk into my machine gun please bring it
again ping it again ah come on ping oh
[ __ ]
there's too many more
we're good we're good we're good this is
a good angle yeah just nothing's coming
behind us yeah we're clear clear okay
clear clear i think there's one more not
clear no the music says we're good bro
uh
i was saying we were good with no
interest i trust i trust you i trust you
i trust the music the music i trust the
game design all right that went better
that went better that was good we're not
dead
uh syringe up here what do these do heel
but also insane they're good for you
yeah you should definitely do that uh no
sean should use this or you or sean
should use this i think right i calm you
can have it bud all right well if you
put it that way oh i was saying that to
sean oh
well you should have you offered it to
two of us and i was giving it to the
other person you offered
[Laughter]
disappointed
there's nothing up here
yeah i must have overlooked it maybe i
was wrong maybe there was why are we in
here for what are we doing in here we're
going through to the other place also uh
tool refill i can't see yeah god damn we
got two on the other side here
oh they're small thank goodness
oh thank goodness
get him don't stop
i wasn't charged why weren't you charged
you charged while you were i forgot that
we just go [ __ ] hate now
now it's unconscious you see me
approaching you know i'm about to hit
it's called teamwork no no i got myself
i [ __ ] perfected it oh it's a stinky
artifactee and uh ammo pack
money the hell is an iix syringe
is this like uh i don't know you might
sean use it though
am i going to collect the whole rainbow
if i uh i've injected myself with the
other one you're going to get all the
diseases you are infected so yeah let's
see what happens
with that
didn't do anything for my health but uh
my infection went up
i'm losing health yeah your rejection
went up yeah
that was not a good syringe i think
are officially our syringe boy i think
mark should take every surrender he is
continuing to lose health
yeah i sure am you know i sure am uh
maybe we could hurry this up maybe we
could uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh purple
all right zone 37
guys well done
oh man
my eyes
no they'll see that
they're throbbing again yeah you know
you got really cool eyesight going on
yeah man
again so is the color this away yeah
where am i going not this way follow me
follow my good eyes
man the colors the reds the reds
reds the brownish reds yeah all the
colors of the pain bow
yes good that makes it funnier uh is
this it the security door i don't know
man does this seem like it 37 37 yeah
that's it
it says diminished alarm yeah well we
have a big-ass stair check uh checkpoint
so
oh but we can't close this
no it's okay you can see from the floor
it still slows them yeah i think what we
do is put turrets like this
and seafoam the stairs the security
squares where do you think they're going
to be
probably out there i don't know probably
it's probably all over the place
let's just go ahead and do the two doors
there's only two doors that connect to
this zone uh unless we haven't
investigated what's on the other side of
this room is this gonna be an awkward
path for them to get through
yeah yeah it won't close but i can put a
turret down and see foam over here to
really try and get kills merrick's still
dying isn't he no i'm fine it's stopped
i'm good
okay i'm fine
i thought we were on the clock here no
no i feel awake
all right i'm gonna a foam grenade this
door cool let's do security [ __ ] and
i'll put mine down once we have an idea
at least there's one down cool sounds
good to me i don't have a lot of ammo
anyway team durian dream team
good they're coming from the right side
that's the foam door exactly like we
produced
who's not
they're banging on the door
yeah there we go we got readings it's
going back up oh cool cool cool got this
one
i put mine at the bottom of the we have
a crossfire at the bottom of the stairs
now love that
here they come
okay
[Music]
one more
[ __ ] oh god the points down there to the
left clear him first
oh reload reload baby
tagging again
why are you down there
let's start the security thing
oh [ __ ]
yeah good job good job
why are you playing the game right
door's done
do not open it all right please dear god
now we now we hide at the top of the tim
yeah yep yeah those scans are clutch by
the way
let me do one more easier to shoot
triangles
that's fine it's all littles
yep gotcha thank you
all right is that all of them i think
that's all i turn it is empty yep all
done
music cam
turret turret i'm a friend friend
oh he's red because he's empty
he
thought he hate me all right one on
other side of door no
tentacles
it'll be real bad i'm just saying oh oh
all right hey can you just die on your
own oh there's one right here too yeah
what do you mean one right yeah what
were you looking in the middle of the
room why would that be the one that i
said was right outside the door no i
thought there was only one total my math
skills were less than adequate well you
gonna hit it or are you gonna look at it
i'm just gonna look at it all right
that's it fair enough
he's really thrilled you're gonna be
pleased
i was trying to aimed dirt through
throbs all right
there's the stairs there there were
stairs i didn't see the stairs guys
are you gonna [ __ ] kill it are you
gonna go up and down the stairs oh you
know you never know when you need some
exercise man got to stay fit wow it's
good to get the cardio in you're not
wrong yeah yeah don't take the escalator
nah at our age you really want to make
sure you get every step you can yeah
refill this is a simple door by the way
what and what accent is that everybody
in blue zergle come on
bubble i think this is our
definitely our final objective across
here
is there like there like dudes over here
no no no no
oh that looks cool
look at this look look whoa that's cool
over there guys ah what is that
clear the operations floor what did you
put are all the things oh oh god
knock oh we have to go in here oh god
what happened to you
wait i don't feel safe
do we agree with this for no reason
i'm going to teleport
hold me
uh no
that's uh
probably good i guess yeah what we're
going left or right is left is just like
a view if it's a view i want to see it
it's a view though
oh that's a good one wait
oh yeah
for sure
i'm not seeing it
oh you see it it's all right give me the
number give me a number it's at uh 150.
i don't look down you no don't look down
look at all the hobos
look contextually from the distance it's
it's right there it's a storm
yeah it's a dust cloud oh what's this
oh what oh
oh
are you okay hey body part oh hi um oh
he [ __ ] himself you know honestly
oh yeah yeah i looked at it oh is he
tongue in the hole if you know what i
mean i said that there's not really much
implication there
i don't like it i don't like it he's
having sex if you know what i mean i
don't be more explicit
in the vajayjay if you know what i mean
deeply concerned about what you think
sex is
it's where you lay there and then a
stork comes in and takes off its
feathers and you all [ __ ] and then
there's a baby
i know for a fact
locate what are we locating alpha 2 and
extract
interpret nav data interpret
underscore nav underscore data
yeah
uh interpreted and interpret
nav
data yep
executing command
oh biometric security clearance required
enter biometric scandal you all are
standing here
we're here yeah oh we're here
what do we get for doing this what's our
reward
freedom satisfaction um oh
cute corners apart
oh
what's happening what's that that's much
bigger than anything we've fought before
oh [ __ ] oh what is that what is that
jesus
oh god oh god oh oh my god
shoot [ __ ]
yeah shoot them oh hang on let me see if
i can tag these things
oh okay the triangles are in the sky now
sure
oh there's more whoa
run
oh [ __ ] run why are we why are we
running oh extraction
cannot terminate quantum tether what
does that mean
it is behind us they're coming through
retreat run run is right you guys need
cover or something you guys good you
good they're fast they're pretty much
this music sounds like it's about to
stop any second and just have the voice
go
run
downtown
i hope we all make it but just in case
we don't i put my turret down and you're
all [ __ ] if you're behind good luck
thank you
you're welcome
wait who has the thing
did no one grab the thing
do we need the no we we're good we're
good we're good we're good
i just see it over there
are these things
bad news a really good time if you tame
it
yeah they do look a little vagina-esque
yeah squint your eyes come with free
hentai
oh squint your eyes at him throw away
your humanity yeah well
did that a long time ago
okay
that's good that was a good day good
yeah
that was crazy all right
vitals critical critical critical fare
so what was with my uh infection what
did that even do
made you really awesome made me awesome
why do we keep getting
[Music]
every pants